jetzt gehe ich ein kleines bisschen
runter zack und ist gesund hallo ich
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge der minecraft fans
bevor ich hier mit infekts anfangen muss
ich euch leider ganz kurz sagen dass in
dieser folge kein geheimnisvolles
geräusch kommt
das liegt ganz einfach daran weil ich
gerade am vorproduzieren bin weil ich ja
drei wochen in den urlaub fahre und da
in der zeit kommen halt 46 folgen und
den nächsten vier folgen also 38 39 40
und 41 in den part wird kein geheimnis
holz geräusch kommt bald ich kann ja
nicht sagen ja kommt setzt eines
folgenschweren von dem erwartet jetzt
mal das hier und dann kann ich ja gar
nicht sagen von - setzte geräusch wahr
weil wenn ich die erste folge auf nehme
sie andere folge noch gar nicht online
gewesen bla bla bla bla auf ihr versteht
was meine am ende der folge kommt eine
kleine frage an euch ich will jetzt
nicht vorher stellen und alles mögliche
ich hoffe ihr könnt mir die beantworten
das gibt mein herz angefangen mit den
freaks und effekt zugesendet von
matthias der meint nämlich einen sound
zwischen zwei steinen mauern ist tiefer
als dem normalen zollen da habe ich
einfach mal so hier genommen habe dass
hier mal einfach hingestellt die können
das sicher so einfach hinstellen und
zwar muss und dass nicht mehr unbedingt
neben die zäune hier stellen oder nehmen
diese zäune sondern ganz einfach neben
diesen stein bauen oder neben bemoosten
steinen bauen das ist relativ egal
ihr seht dass hier schon wenn ich jetzt
quasi hier man den boden ging das dass
ich gehen ein bisschen heran also erst
jetzt nicht sieht dann sollte er zum
augenoptiker gehen obwohl ich vielleicht
auch bald in grüne bekomme aber ich sehe
ist also das recht des steintors vier
viel tiefer wenn jetzt mal einen blog
kaputt mache seht ihr es geht also ich
setze mein block hin
es ist nur tiefer wenn das sound mit
beiden seiten mit dem steintor verbunden
ist als ich mal seht ihr dann wird es
tiefer weiß ich dass diese zahl diesem
stein anpasst deswegen nutze ich jetzt
auch beim einer map diese steine hier
als abgrenzung und komme ich schnell die
frage man jetzt schon mal wisst ihr ich
hab aus in die welt kreiert und habe
gesagt kommen ohne cheats und immer wenn
ich jetzt reingehen muss sich kurz im
lan öffnen machen und dann muss ich
sagen dies erlauben weil ich sonst keine
commands eingeben kann sowas wie tmz 0
oder so wisst ihr irgendwie wie ich es
will
map um teleportieren creative mode web
also ich bin zu einem creative suite
sind aus wie krieg schied an ohne die
man zu öffnen ist super wenn ihr mir
helfen könntet aber das perfekt nummer
eins kommentiert und es ist sie auf
jeden fall cool und ich denke nicht dass
es ein bisher aufgefallen ist fakt
nummer zwei ist eine ganz kuriose sache
und zwar wurde mir zugesendet von paulo
oder paul oder soleil seit er
geschrieben halo karl weiß er dass
partikel auf dem boden erscheinen wenn
man irgendwo runter fällt diese
erscheinen um creative mottos einer höhe
für die zum beispiel 20 blöcken einfach
durchgehen runter bis auf den boden
fliegt dann sind sie nämlich auch zu den
obwohl man ja nicht fällt sondern nur
auf dem boden runter so dass wir jetzt
ein bisschen schneller vorgetragen mit
wir immer ein bisschen vorankommen also
ich habe mir wieder so ein tolles schild
geschrieben fall partikel kommen auch um
creative modus super luca danke so also
ihr kennt es moment ich lieg mal nach
oben zu ein bisschen so ich gehe in den
games 0-ports und ihr seht so ein paar
partikel da wenn ich allerdings in game
und 1 zb dass castro fliege und mich
dann runter zu kennen also ganz ganz
langsam und ich gleich auf den boden
kommt trotzdem die partikel
das ist so weil sich die partikel nicht
nach dem gamer richten sondern einfach
nach der entfernung die vom aufprallort
bis zum absprung ort und einfach bei
einem game und 1 kriegt man halt kein
ton dabei er sich ist es knackt dieses
knochenbrüche zeugs krams sondern man
kriegt halt nur diese partikel die einem
zeigen okay kommt was relativ weit oben
bin ich von hierunter fallen würde
wenn das ein bisschen wenn ich
allerdings wie schon vorhin von keine
ahnung hier runter gehen würde dann seht
ihr tag kommen so die artikel und die
sind nämlich genauso die partikel wie
wenn ich von hier einfach so runter
fallen würde
okay ich hatte jetzt ein bisschen höher
fliegen müssen aber auf jeden fall danke
an dich paul es ist allen denke ich
schon mal aufgefallen
aber niemand hat sich glaube ich so
einer darüber gedanken macht ein
kontrast und realtiv mode also das ja
schon irgendwie witzig und wer das
witzig findet er den komischen humor der
nächste effekt kommt ebenfalls von
matthias matthias ich hoffe dass ihr
selbst herausgefunden weil ich nehme nur
facts die e mail per mail an kontrakte
gmail.com zusendet und ich nehme mir
nichts aus irgendwelchen anderen videos
sondern das sind denn schon wenn das aus
andere videos ist dann sind das die
leute die mit weg zu senden
also matthias ich vertraue da mal ihr
kennt es ich habe eine karte ich guckte
er draufhat wundervoll wenn ich auf 1
druck ist die karte
also die karte bot sich hat geht raus
hier seht ihr übrigens meine welt
das ist hier dieses abgesperrte bereich
und sonst noch was so und jetzt achtet
macht die karte die ist oben so ein
bisschen vom rand entfernt um unten so
ein bisschen von dem von der
inventarliste wenn ich mal rein gehe ist
die oben gar nicht mehr vom rand
entfernt und die liegt unten auf der
inventarliste am besten sieht man so
dass man da einfach dran somit kommt man
jetzt und guck mal jetzt jetzt bin ich
nämlich genau auf wasser wird und jetzt
gehe ich ein kleines bisschen runter
zack und ist ran gesucht das ist witzig
im wasser sucht man an die karte ran
ich weiß nicht ob man im wasser sucht
man auch immer mal so ein bisschen an
seine eigene hand dran wenn dir das mal
anschaut aber an die karte
beispielsweise auch da war ich habe
genau was er will erst einmal egal ob
hier versucht man ein bisschen dran dann
kann ich meine e mails gecheckt wurde
wir zugewendet von nils und zwar
schreibt erst mal wenn du das liest dann
heißt du kontrakt auf youtube gar nicht
gedacht hey ich wollte sagen das muss
sie noch klein sind beziehungsweise noch
babys und roppen diese auch keine ip das
ist mittlerweile auch so wenn jeder
folge finde ich irgendwas neues raus die
keine erfahrung droppen erstmals
villiger dann waren es was passt dann
sonst wäre ja dann war's das war es denn
danach fledermäuse und jetzt habe ich
schon ein kleines türchen gemacht und
wir denen ich habe ein paar sachen spawn
als beispielsweise meine kuh frau das
baby co das brauche ich damals scharf
eigentlich wollte die bahn aber es geht
ja so auch wenn man darauf klickt so und
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mir mal
ein schwert zu nehmen und mich in den
game mode 0 damit man besser zeigen kann
ihr seht ich hab keine level dann wird
auch so bleiben so der drop nix die
kleine schiebe drop nix und die
elisabeth grossmann sprecher von lenkern
dauert aber seine ihre mutter die job
was und die mutter auch von gp und die
mutter vom schwein für der fall auch
also kleine kinder job noch keine
erfahrung sammeln quasi diese erfahrung
was hat er dazu auf geplant hin so
schwarz keine ahnung
die die sammel quasi ihre erfahrung wenn
sie größer werden ihre lebenserfahrungen
wenn man sie tötet dann bekommt man erst
die erfahrung wenn sie größer sind weil
dann haben die schon erfahrung
lebenserfahrung wenn sie klein sind sie
sehr kalt essen geboren haben noch keine
erfahrung mit dem leben gemacht so
kombiniert mit das letzte mal grad
und ich würde sagen das war's dann auch
schon wieder mit den facts wie gesagt
ich bin vor produzieren die frage habt
ihr euch ja ganz schön gestellt bitte
helft mir also meine sache ist ich habe
diese welt erstellt und gebaut und alles
mögliche und hat schon kleinen moment
gedauert
ich hab kein bock das noch mal zu machen
allerdings habe ich von anfang an gesagt
dies erlauben aus kriege ich das
irgendwie umgestellt in einer datei oder
so musste etwas anders eingeben wenn ihr
das wisst dann helfen auf jeden fall
schreibt bitte in die kommentare das
wäre super nett von euch und da will ich
sagen wir sehen uns nächsten
ich weiß jetzt die folge am dienstag
kommt auf jeden fall nächste woche weil
die werde ich jetzt produzieren die
folge die kommt auf jeden fall nächste
woche die nächsten vier folgen kommen
immer passend die nächsten drei folgen
und wenn es euch gefällt es mit einer
bewertung